they came by the thousands to demand
germany's government change its course
in the corona crisis
but for many the demonstrations in the
heart of berlin ended in arrest
police say they were forced to make the
detentions after far-right activists who
marched
alongside coronavirus skeptics clashed
with police
a small group even managed to storm the
steps of the german parliament
before being detained
[Applause]
saturday's demonstrations attracted a
wide coalition of activists
from right-wing radicals to those who
reject the authority of the german
government
or doubt the severity or even existence
of the pandemic they were unified by one
belief
the government's measures to tackle the
coronavirus pandemic go too
far personally i don't believe that
there's a pandemic
i do think the disease exists but not a
pandemic
according to the new definition of a
pandemic it's a pandemic
but that has to do with how much it's
spread and not with how dangerous it is
authorities demanded protesters adhere
to mask and social distancing
requirements during the demonstrations
requirements many participants flouted a
predictable development
says berlin's interior senator
i certainly would have liked to avoid
scenes like this because berlin's police
predicted that today would turn out like
this
with thousands of people not respecting
distancing rules
but despite the arrests thousands
continued their march
a clear sign that their anger is here to
stay
well for more on this i'm joined by our
political correspondent emmanuel sharz
who has been following the protest for
us these
pictures and are quite incredible how
significant is it
that demonstrators are able to get first
past police and then all the way to the
doors
of the reichstag building well it's
pretty significant indeed and
those pictures are indeed very striking
very shocking for the german
population and i think worldwide
interior minister josefa
to that he said that the reichstag
building is a seat of
our parliament and a symbolic center of
a free democracy he also said that it
was intolerable that rioters and
extremists abuse it for their own
purposes
he also went on to salute the police
officer's conduct
yesterday he said i thank the police for
preventing that so quickly and
decisively
and the state must show zero tolerance
and take robust action against such
people so quite a strong stance by
interior minister
host zafar however when he addresses the
police's reaction
we can see in the images from
yesterday's uh
assault attempted assault on the
parliament that even if a 3000
police officers were in berlin were
deployed yesterday also some
coming from other german regions well
police seem to be overwhelmed for a
moment
before they could prevent activists and
rioters to enter the parliament the
police
spokesperson also said that the police
simply couldn't be
everywhere at the same time also a
strong reaction by foreign minister
haikomas who said
everyone has the right to disagree about
coronavirus
measures and to demonstrate but no one
and he stressed that in capital letters
on his twitter account
should be marching behind right-wing
extremists putting
police officers in danger and exposing
others to the risk of infection
so this is quite an event here in
germany their toyotas might try to enter
the parliament
they're incredible there's so many
takeaways but the number 38 000
demonstrators
is that number now too significant to
dismiss this notion that they are
only far right-wing fringe groups or
anti-vaxxers
they're not only far-right uh groups
there's a socially mixed group of people
we've seen in the report people who are
worried about the consequences of the
measures being taken by the government
to tackle the pandemic
they're worried about the impact it can
have on their lives on their jobs
they worry that it might impact on their
freedoms
but the thing is that what we see the
most are the
most vocal the most visible protesters
those who are waving
german imperial flags for example those
who are waving a pro-trump or pro
putin banners we were talking in the
report about the number of arrests
around
300 in total including 200 that took
place in front of the russian embassy
where 3 000 protesters right-wing
protesters
continued on even after the protest the
official protest was
disbanded so a group that is not only
composed by far-right
protesters that's a minority but a very
visible and a very vocal minority
political correspondent emmanuel shares
thank you so much
you